loin des regards dans le petit gymnase
de terre sainte mais aussi loin du faste
et des paillettes
le petit club de gymnastique mobilise
ses compétitrices pour une action un peu
particulière c'est bon c'est bien
entraîné impeccable maintenant les
filles on passe à l'opération
développement durable qu'on a mis en
place
on va se répartir les tâches d'accord
allez on y va c'est parti défi notre
département compte plus d'une vingtaine
de salles avec un équipement minimum à
la pratique de près de trois mille deux
cents licenciés
ainsi pour limiter les coûts d'une
structure associative
l'éducateur a eu une drôle d'idée on a
récupéré avec les parents et les
gymnastes des matelas des du polystyrène
etc
qu'ils allaient jeter et on récupère
tout ça on à stocker tout ça ici pour
que la pendant les vacances on puisse
fabriquer des modules de gymnastique
mais pourquoi vous les achetez pas comme
tout le monde
et ben parce que il faut beaucoup
d'argent et nous on en a comment dire on
est limité en budget des jeunes filles
qui réfléchissent leur pratique alors
que la tendance en plus à la
consommation et à la prestation de
services dans le mouvement sportif
hop il ya certaines entreprises qui
payent pour détruire le polystyrène
alors qu'eux ils sont super contents de
nous en donner
voilà donc j'espère que tout le monde va
faire pareil maintenant un vrai travail
d'équipé
on a peint les murs pour le bureau sa
plus jolie
on a fait dix modules ont amélioré ma on
est fiers on est comment on va on va
mettre ça ici on va baisser ça dans le
fond donc ça ne gène pas n'a pas de
parents d'élèves de maman d'élève à la
couture bas le but c'était pas ça en
fait ils ont pas trop réalisé ce que je
voulais voilà ils n'ont pas trop réalisé
c'est là maintenant les filles qui sont
sur le terrain qui font la couture qui
colle le policier rennes etc
c'est là où elle réalise que on est en
train de faire ça voilà la différence de
prix ne vont pas le savoir parce
qu'elles n'ont jamais payé mais
un module comme celui là qui coûte 200
euros il va revenir 20 euros là c'est
bien pour pour les filles de dd un peu
leur club en faisant de la récupération
en recyclant et puis c'est leur soutien
au site d'entraînement donc c'est bien
pour elle de voir qu'elles ont participé
à 10 heures à l'équipement de leur club
est-ce que vous pensez que ça les fait
grandir aussi probablement parce que ça
les interroge sur
les problèmes de récupération de
développement durable 2
de l'environnement du tout jetable
seconde tout le texte herald
bon indicateur à la fin de la séance les
jeunes filles ne voulaient plus quitter
le gymnase être acteur de sa pratique et
trouver des solutions pour ne pas
gaspiller avec utilité était l'objectif
des petites actions qui peuvent servir
d'exemple et donner des idées
une certitude ces vacances sont un
succès